alerte sur internet et le pire est sans
doute à venir à l'ouverture des bureaux
demain virus informatiques depuis la
nuit dernière à déjà terrassé des
millions d'ordinateurs dans le monde
entier un virus d'un genre nouveau
affectant n'importe quel ordinateur il
suffit simplement qu'ils soient
connectés à internet et les dégâts sont
d'importance nos confrères de l'agencé
france presse par exemple ont été
sérieusement perturbé les explications
de marie pierre ses amitiés et christian
galley voici le nom de ce virus ça
certes c'est un dérivé du virus blaster
qui avait infecté des millions
d'ordinateurs en août 2003 il se répand
automatiquement il suffit que votre
ordinateur soit connecté sur internet et
qu'on clique sur explorer le navigateur
de windows saute quand même plus en fait
si sow d'un ordinateur à notre sueur du
wan pages et des pages internet est
directement il rentre dans l'ordinateur
et l'infect les ordinateurs de
simplement c'est ce qu'il s'est passé
ici à l' agence france presse à paris
l'attaqué du virus a eu lieu brutalement
hier soir il était à peu près 18h20
quand la plupart des ordinateurs de la
salle où vous êtes ici se sont éteints
puis relancé automatiquement dans le
même temps les ordinateurs qui envoie
nos productions vers le satellite
lesquels satellite sera distribué à nos
clients se sont bloquées sous l' attaque
du virus donc c'était clairement une
attaque virale il a fallu plusieurs
heures et une équipe de quinze
informaticiens pour que tout rentre dans
l'ordre
à minuit les sociétés spécialisées dans
la fabrication d'antivirus donne déjà
depuis ce matin des détails sur leur
site pour éliminer ça sert
dès qu'il est entré dans le système
l'ordinateur c'est un puits se rallument
plusieurs fois de suite
des dizaines de virus sont créés chaque
semaine par des passionnés
d'informatique ou des hackers difficile
de savoir à quelle vitesse se propage ça
sert certains spécialistes mettent en
garde sur sa rapidité mais on saura à
l'ampleur des dégâts demain lorsque tout
le monde aura repris le travail